how's it going bros my sponsor today
we're gonna play today we're gonna play
multiplayer games that we found that I
found you didn't do anything
you're just here because I haven't
taught Edgar how to play yet Wow
first game in with you because then
we're gonna eat it's called coro coro
coro coro
we are the same head the point of the
game is to collect as much from there we
go I am going yes all the sushi wait
where'd you get my art but or how did we
get the same oh damn it I ate it anyway
oh my god no it's my food its man we
both ate it
we don't slap me with that penis on
where did we buy our tank top I won
again all right last one morg
hey Lester high five high five
Oh everyone there was so much what I'm
fingering near back I know you're
winning what the hell
oh you send me if I'd make money feed me
feed me
Wow what okay no I don't swear to god
that's already good all right that was
kuru kuru kuru base gaming next game the
goal of the game is to become the most
fashionable attractive wrestler ever
well I like where this is going waiting
is simple just be the one who doesn't
die I don't what is this there we go all
right where do I get a better outfit now
oh why do I not get a better outfit now
I thought the photo was to be battle is
what oh I'm so good you're so bad yeah
you get a hot yes
oh hi tingles
I'm ready cuz I don't know the controls
this is awesome look at my eye from
my butt oh my god
you murderer
I love the characters know what I want
for where he's like oh my boy oh my boy
we have a winner but you're all awesome
I'm the king
let's try another game would I want to
be the nipple man hipper man oh yeah man
okay I don't know what the difference I
think I know I like the ribbon we get
when we did Oh ribbon who would she get
a point for every ribbon you okay girl
doesn't matter no way your nipple oh oh
did you see that
from the hill yeah
[Music]
yeah stupid game alright look a tiny I'm
alright I hope you enjoyed watching if
you did go ahead and leave a like and
maybe Edgar will visit you when you
sleep in your dreams in your nightmares
stay awesome bros thank you for watching
Brophy